der eagle has landed so hieß es vor fast
50 jahren 2009/10 jährt sich die
mondlandung der apollo 11 1969 zum
fünfzigsten mal heute gibt es eine
weitere pioniertat zu verkünden zum
ersten mal ist eine mondsonde auf der
rückseite des mondes gelandet und zwar
eine chinesische
damit haben die chinesen einen
meilenstein erreicht denn auf der
rückseite des mondes zu landen ist nicht
gerade einfach weswegen ist bisher auch
noch niemand gewagt hat klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende wissenschafts videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen
bisher haben es alle weltraum nationen
gescheut auf der rückseite zu landen
weil das mit deutlich erhöhtem aufwand
verbunden ist denn nicht nur der länder
muss zum mond geschickt werden sondern
auch ein mond satellit als relaisstation
um die signale an die erde zu senden
denn ein solcher länder kann von der
rückseite nicht direkt senden oder
empfangen weil der mond dazwischen ist
das geht nur über einen satelliten der
von der erde aus gesehen werden kann und
damit funkkontakt zur erde haben kann
und eben auch vom länder quasi über eck
wird dann gesendet und empfangen
und das bedeutet auch dass die landung
nicht direkt kontrolliert werden kann
alles geht nur über den satelliten
deshalb musste dieser satellit extra für
diese mission im mai in den mond orbit
gebracht werden und noch etwas ist
schwieriger auf der rückseite des mondes
sie ist nicht so eben wie die
vorderseite eine landung ist auch
deswegen dort schwieriger jetzt ist es
also gelungen um 3 uhr 36
mitteleuropäischer zeit jetzt wird ein
roboterfahrzeug den länder verlassen und
die umgebung untersuchen neben diversen
messgeräten ist auch eine panorama
kamera an bord zusätzlich ist auch ein
kleines gewächshaus mit auf dem mond und
es wird getestet die pflanzen bei der
niedrigen gravitation des mondes wachsen
und es werden niedrig frequent radio
frequenzen gemessen
auf der rückseite des mondes gibt es
kaum störungen durch strahlung von der
erde so dass man hier erhofft deutlich
ungestörter ins all zu horchen zudem ist
ein strahlenmessgerät der kieler
christian-albrechts-universität mit
dabei dass die strahlung und den
wassergehalt des bodens messen wird und
im kommenden jahr wird es für die
chinesen weiter gehen mit scharnier fünf
wollen sie mondgestein 1 sammeln und zur
erde zurückbringen und
2013 soll ein chinese zum ersten mal
seinen fuß auf den mond setzen und auch
flüge zum mars sind geplant der wettlauf
ins all ist also in vollem gange und wir
können gespannt sein wer als erstes den
fuß auf den mars setzen wird wenn es
dazu neues gibt erfahrt ihr es natürlich
bei pixum auch auf dem englischen kanal
wo es heute für euch eine videopremiere
gibt led lights damage ist der vater von
led lampen für unsere augen gefährlich
sind
ich freue mich auf euch auf dem
englischen kanal zu tun
stay tuned